Let's go next to our caller from the eight
Oh five area code. Who is calling today from
eight Oh five.
That will be me, David. Uh, my name is Gabriel.
Hey Gabriel.
And uh, I'm pulling from, hi, I'm calling
from Canada park. Uh, I am an independent,
um, by have a Twitter. I just started a Twitter
account not long ago called the Gabriel with
a V as in Victor messenger.
All right.
Um, so I want to talk to the about, um, the
news. Uh, just a little bit about myself.
I'm from Mexico. I came here when I was 17,
and so for asylee only have any documents
for seven years, even though my mother was
a U S citizen, then I became a, a riskier
than, uh, alien. Huh. And then I became a
us citizen, uh, in 2001. Uh, so, but I wouldn't
talk about the news. Uh, I see that we emphasize
too much. Uh, Donald Trump, maybe we should
be emphasizing a little bit more, uh, you
know, Bernie Sanders, at least I know that
we need to talk about Donald Trump and all
the things that he's been doing wrong, you
know. Um, but maybe we should talk also more
about Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders.
I voted for Bernie Sanders and the last time,
you know, and I was really upset that Hillary
Clinton stole the nomination with the DNC,
um, from, you know, from Bernie Sanders.
Um, so I don't know. And the reason I see
these is because I don't know if you've ever
seen that movie the secret where they talk
about where, okay, so they took about worthy,
we put the energy. Um, you know, what we took
about these were all the energy goes students.
So it seems like we're putting too much energy
into Donald Trump. I know that we have to
criticize what he's been doing wrong, as I
said before, but I think that we also need
to emphasize more what Bernie Sanders was
to do. And Alexandria Ocasio Cortez and Elisa,
that Warren, I also happen to like Tulsi Gabbard
a lot myself.
Teresa Gabbard. Yeah,
the, yeah, I know that, um, you know, she
hasn't done that great. I don't know why I
think that she should have a greater following.
Um, but going back to the news, uh, my question
is where do you stand when it comes to Fox
news? All the damage they do, um, because
even though they not the ones throwing the
stone, they are the ones given the stones.
And I'm referring also to the Megan Phelps
interview that you had with her, which was
great. Um, and so I'm seeing a lot of things.
I'm sorry.
Yeah. What was your question today specifically
though?
So question is, do you think that we should,
um,
[inaudible]
ban certain social media and news outlets
when they have such a hateful discourse about
religion?
Basically? No. I think when you, because in
order to do that you need to establish, um,
someone who will do the banning, and then
anytime that you do that, it becomes subject
to the whims of the presidential, um, uh,
desires. Uh, it becomes subject to the whims
of whoever is in the white house at the time.
And in general, I am for more speech as long
as it is not criminal. And so we need to criticize
Fox news. We need to criticize outlets that
are problematic. There are certain things
of course, that that would be against the
law. Um, but no, I don't think we need to
start banning social media platforms or channels
as a, as a, as a matter of principle. No.
Okay. And my second last question is, uh,
so I guess it's a comment I really liked what
Megan Phelps said during the interview, which
is the way to reach people on the other side.
I considered myself, by the way, uh, was a
maybe a progressive conservative. Okay. Um,
and so what she said, and you said also is
reaching the people, not so much with facts,
but maybe with, you know, as human beings,
real emotions, what do you think about that?
To be able to convert them?
Yeah, I've been talking about that for years.
Every time I speak to, you know, a former
white nationalist or whoever it is, it is
empathy and human connections that either
prevent them from getting into those ideologies
or, or that get them out. So I could not agree
more with what Megan said about that.
Awesome. Thank you so much.
All right, very good. Appreciate the phone
call. Great to hear from you